el presidente don al tram finalmente
cumple una promesa de su campaña de hace
cuatro años y ha dado órdenes de reducir
las fuerzas estadounidenses a sólo dos
mil quinientos tanto en afganistán como
en irak este será el número más bajo de
tropas sobre el terreno en los últimos
veinte años mientras que la propuesta
marca una victoria para trump algunos
miembros de su administración están
preocupados de que el movimiento podría
tener consecuencias catastróficas
mons
creo que es extremadamente importante
que en los próximos meses no haya ningún
cambio en lo que respecta a la defensa y
la política exterior
osei
creo que una reducción precipitada en
afganistán o irak sería un error
las órdenes de retirar las tropas vienen
solo meses después de que la
administración trump logró un acuerdo
con el movimiento talibán para eliminar
todas las fuerzas estadounidenses para
el próximo mes de mayo pero los críticos
dicen que el grupo no ha cumplido su
parte del trato de reducir los ataques
violentos contra las fuerzas del
gobierno afgano a algunos les preocupa
que la retirada precipitada de tropas
pueda socavar las negociaciones pero el
pentágono quiere tranquilizar a los
escépticos
todos ejecutaremos este
reposicionamiento de manera que proteja
a nuestros hombres y mujeres
combatientes a nuestros socios en la
comunidad de inteligencia y al cuerpo
diplomático ya nuestros magníficos
aliados que son críticos para
reconstruir las capacidades de seguridad
afganas e iraquíes y la sociedad civil
estos aires
el retiro debe terminarse cinco días
antes de que yo badén asuma el cargo los
expertos advierten que el momento de la
retirada podría presentar un nuevo
desafío cuando se mude a la casa blanca